so if we look at the planet we could
maybe construct a typology where we have
on the top here brother sort of wide
lands areas with less human impact but
then it's a succession of increasing
human impact all the way down where we
have severely degraded habitats and I
think the policy for a more sustainable
management of ecosystems in the world
will have to be directed how do we stay
away from ending up at the bottom how do
we maintain most of the planet somewhere
in between these two how do we encourage
our management of natural resources that
will maintain our essential functions
ecological structures functions and
processes to deliver the ecosystem
services on which human are dependent
and we need to put this in a perspective
that we we need to actually be able to
feed another fifty percent more people
until 2050 and this is a tremendous
challenge and I will explain why it is a
challenge and that is that for many
areas of the world we're already at the
bottom where we have rather severe
degradation of the soil and I think this
map we see the red errors being brother
severe degraded areas these are areas
where we actually need to be very
innovative and think how could we
restore this area to be again productive
and continue to production of ecosystem
services I think the most modern
definition of restoration is is a
process of assisting the recovery of an
ecosystem that has been degraded damaged
or destroyed so this is a very pragmatic
definition that you're not including any
specific target that you're restoring to
certain condition that happened to be at
that area hundred years ago or 200 years
ago this pragmatic definition just tells
you that you will assist in the recovery
process from a very low productive state
and then we looked after literature on
the cost of restoration and again we
didn't have 2,000 studies to start with
just a handful that actually provided a
cost of restoration so so these are the
average there are quite high numbers but
this is what you would expect in urban
areas particularly when when you have to
deal with our poor soil conditions but
again then we looked at the benefit cost
ratios and we put the urban like in that
if again and interesting it had it sort
of ends up here in the right part of the
figure you have a range from about 2 to
15 but it's comparable to the benefit
cost ratio is for forest or woodlands in
more rural areas and again this will not
take into account the cultural values of
these and we have not taken into the
counter health value so if we do the
health value this might just spike right
up restoration in urban area given the
complexities and then high cost is still
has a range that is substantial and this
should actually be on the table in in
the urban planning that when you're
deciding what to do if you have
industrial area brown fill area which
you're planning to develop that that
could be different options that you're
of course you build new housing and you
build malls and you build infrastructure
but this could also be part of that
planning and actually taking encounter
benefits of the that restoration and
given that it could actually be much
much higher than we have have indicated
here
and also one thing we didn't take you
into account is sort of the value these
ecosystems could have an urban landscape
when it comes to climate change this is
what all cities have to face and how to
adapt to climate change and also the
transformation to a future beyond fossil
fuel
you